SETH STERNBERG: Well thank you
all very much for coming to
Google I/O. We really
appreciate it.
My name is Seth.
And I'm the Product Management
Director
for the Google+ Platform.
DAVID GLAZER: I'm David, the
Engineering Director for
Google+ Platform.
SETH STERNBERG: So we're going
to take you guys through an
overview of the various tools
that are available from the
Google+ Platform today.
And first, we just
want to start.
This is very new, the
Google+ Platform.
So we just wanted to start
with what is the platform
really about?
What are we trying
to accomplish?
And at a very high level, we're
trying to help bring the
best of Google to the rest of
the internet and enable a user
to bring their internet
back to Google.
So it's really creating a
connection, between a user and
their Google experience and the
rest of the internet and
everything, that they experience
on the internet,
back to Google.
So you wondering, what does
that actually mean, right?
Well, let's just drop
right into a story.
So let's say that I'm
doing a Map search.
And I'm kind of like, OK, I want
to see a movie tonight.
And as I'm doing this search,
I get a notification.
And you guys have probably
seen this before, the red
square with the white number,
the notifier that's across all
Google properties.
So I just got a notification,
that dropped in on me, when I
was on Google Maps.
And I click it.
And so when I click that,
I see come up a
message from David.
And he's saying, hey, let's
grab dinner tonight.
So I want to see more.
What is David actually
trying to say to me.
So I go ahead and
I click that.
And I get the full post
that came in.
And it looks like David shared
something from Open Table.
And it says, let's grab dinner
and a movie tonight.
How about Zero Zero, which
is a local restaurant?
So I'm like, OK, let's see
what Zero Zero is about.
There's a very clear Action
Button right there and View
Menu button.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and click that.
And when I do so, I just get
taken straight to Open Table,
right into their.
Site and I go right to the
menu page in Open Table.
So Zero comes up, and I scroll
through the menu.
And I think, yeah, this is
actually a pretty good place.
Why don't we go ahead and
make a reservation.
So I'm going to find a table.
I'm going to get a
bunch of options.
And I'm going to Accept,
click 5:45.
And in order to make a
reservation at Open Table, of
course, you have to login.
Because they need to
know who you are.
So Open Table is one of the many
people who've integrated
Google+ Sign-In, which you saw
a little bit about at the
keynote address.
So I want to go ahead and choose
to sign in with Google.
And when I do that, I get a
standard consent dialogue that
comes up and says, hey, this
is the information you're
going to send about yourself
to Open Table.
And this is the information from
Open Table that's going
to come back to Google.
So I'm going to go ahead
and Accept and
sign-in to Open Table.
Now this is really special,
what just happened.
Right here, Google just noticed
that I actually have
an Android device.
And because I have an Android
device, which does not yet
have the Open Table application
on it, we're
proactively asking me if I'd
like to download the Open
Table Android app.
It's the absolutely smoothest
experience for a user to get a
mobile application
onto their phone.
All of this happening when
a user chooses to
connect on the web.
So I'm going to go ahead
and do this.
I'm going to say, yes,
I'd like to install
the Open Table app.
So of course, I'm on
the web, right?
I've just gone in through
the sign-in flow.
I'm now signed in.
And because I'm signed in, my
reservation is now confirmed.
So I've just gone ahead and
made a reservation at Open
Table for dinner for David
and I tonight.
DAVID GLAZER: So now
we're planning
our evening out together.
And Seth took care of dinner,
so I decided, let's see if I
can find a movie for
us to go to.
And I like to use Fandango
to buy my movie tickets.
So I go to Google, search
for Fandango.
And what I see is not only I can
find Fandango, but I also
see some great suggestions for
movies that other people, who
use Google and Fandango, have
been interested in lately.
And it reminded me, oh, I've
been meaning to see the new
Iron Man movie.
Let me check it out.
So I go ahead, click
on "Iron Man".
And there, right in Fandango,
is the trailer.
I watch the trailer.
It is going to be awesome.
Enough things explode.
I definitely want to go
see this tonight.
So I go ahead.
And I'm going to buy
some tickets.
But I'm also going to tell Seth,
you should check this
out, because I just
bought us tickets.
We're going to have a great
time at this movie.
SETH STERNBERG: So when David
shares that, with me, from
Fandango, I get a notification,
once again, on
any Google property, including
on my Android device.
So I just pull out my Android
device, which I got a
notification on.
And I see, it looks like David
has shared something with me.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click into that
and see what happens.
Tap into it, as the
case may be.
So I tap in, and I
see he's buying
tickets at 6:00 PM tonight.
Now that's a small problem,
because, as you all remember,
I made my reservation
for 5:45 at dinner.
So I'm going to fix
this conflict.
So we're now on my mobile phone,
obviously, so I'm going
to go to my application
launcher.
I have Open Table on my phone,
already, because I downloaded
it when I was initially
registering with Open Table.
And when I go ahead and tap on
Open Table, like you guys just
on the keynote this morning,
I am already connected.
I am already signed in
on the mobile device.
I don't have to touch
anything.
Open Table just knows
who I am.
And the application is
completely relevant to me,
because I've already connected
on the web.
So Open Table has my
dining points.
They have my profile picture,
my name, all the standard
information about me.
And of course, they also have
my reservations that I've
already made.
So I'm going to go ahead and
tap on Zero Zero, the
reservation I made for
David and I tonight.
And that'll bring me into the
reservation, and I can go
ahead and change that
reservation.
So that story, I think,
illustrates a completely
seamless experience, where all
the technology, all the
computing just kind of fades
into the background.
And it was so easy for David and
me to coordinate, in this
case, dinner and a movie this
evening, just one, simple,
fluid flow from the user's
perspective.
Open Table just appeared
on my phone.
Once I connected to Open Table
on the web, I was connected to
Open Table on mobile.
It just knew who I was.
David found things in search
based on what other people
were doing inside Fandango.
Fandango was telling Google,
hey, here's what's happening
inside our application.
And we brought the best
of Fandango to users
as they did a search.
So one simple fluid flow that
just makes computing fall into
the background.
Now, we launched Google+ Sign-In
just two months ago.
So it's really new.
And we thought we'd tell you a
little bit about what we're
hearing from the market.
So one of the launch developers,
The Fancy,
proactively emailed
us and said this.
And we're like, hey, guys,
that's awesome.
Can we tell everybody else what
you guys just told us?
And what they're telling us is
the conversion they're seeing,
from Google+ Sign-In, is besting
that of other social
networks, across every platform,
Android, iOS, web.
And then, from another one of
our launch partners, from "The
Guardian," they told us that, on
Android, 41% of their users
are choosing Google+ Sign-In.
And that is the number social
sign-in option on Android.
Last night, we held a dinner for
some of our partners, who
you can see in the Sandbox
later today.
And one of those partners
implemented Google+ Sign-In
three weeks ago.
And they shared, with David
and I last night, that in
those three weeks, Google+
Sign-In has literally become
the number one social login
choice for users who are
connecting with their
application.
So some other stats, 40%,
this blew our minds.
When a user is asked, do you
want to install the Android
app, when they are on the web,
so that flow you saw in Open
Table, where when a user
is connecting with your
application on the web, 40%
say, yes, I do want
to install the app.
There is no higher conversion
mechanism that I know of to
enable a user to install your
Android application.
40% of users who are asked if
they'd like to install an
Android application, through
that flow, are saying, yes.
That is incredible.
And then another step, those
interactive posts, where David
shared with me the menu in Open
Table and then shared
with that he'd like to go see
"Iron Man 3" from Fandango,
those interactive posts are
getting three times the
engagement rate of a normal
post inside Google.
Three times.
When we saw that, that was kind
of the sleeper hit of
Google+ Sign-In.
We just did not expect we'd get
that level of engagement
from sharing inside an app.
And in retrospect, it's
really obvious, right?
We're giving users a really
clear call to action.
David's not just saying, hey,
I'm sharing something from
Open Table.
He's saying, click here
to view the menu.
I want you to do something.
I want you to engage with me.
And that turns out to be
very, very powerful.
So in sum, what you can see,
is that we've created an
experience that's
just completely
seamless for a user.
It just makes it so easy to
just live your life, on a
daily basis, and use a service
that you trust, like Google+,
to connect with applications and
to bring the best of your
Google experience with you to
the rest of the internet and
then that rest of the internet
back to Google.
And now you can see
it in action.
So now David's going to walk
through some very specific
products and how to actually
make them work.
DAVID GLAZER: Thanks.
So Seth gave you the
overall context.
You saw the story.
We're connecting what you do
on Google to what you do
everywhere else.
And I'm going to walk through,
in not a deep dive but a sort
of medium deep dive, on eight
different features.
I'm going to talk about four
features that are really about
how we take what happens in
your apps, what happens as
users are browsing your
site, and how we can
bring that into Google.
And then we're going to talk
about four features that go
the other direction and take
the power of Google, the
capabilities of Google, and help
bring them into your app.
Let's get started with
first feature.
This is a very straightforward
feature.
Someone's looking for
you on Google.
They're doing a search.
They're trying to find your
brand, your product, your
presence, your company,
whatever it is.
In addition, to the normal
results, over on the left, we
also have this panel on the
right, where you can see,
here's recent posts from
"National Geographic," here's
the conversation, the
information, that I'm trying
to get out to my audience now.
So what does it take
to do this?
This one actually doesn't
take coding.
This one just takes--
set up a Google+ page
and, once you set up
the page, use it.
If you have something to
say to your users,
say it, share things.
And when you share them and
people search for you on
Google, we'll show
it up in Google.
It's probably the simplest
way to start having a
conversation, with your users,
inside Google, from your app.
Let's go a tiny bit deeper and
say that we also want to
affect some of the things that
appear on the left side of
Search, in the ads and in the
organic search results, in the
main section there,
on the left.
If you notice, up at the top,
you can see that this add,
because a lot of people have
been interacting with this
advertiser, we can
highlight that.
We think that's useful
information to
people viewing the add.
So we highlight it.
And similarly, you can see that,
in the Search results,
if people, me or people I care
about, have said, hey, I'm
interested in this piece of
content, I recommend this
piece of content, we
highlight that.
That's useful information to
people searching, so we're
going to show that.
So how do you send those signals
over to Google so
Google knows that this might
be information worth
highlighting?
Pretty simple, you put a couple
buttons on your site.
You put Follow button,
if you want people
to follow your presence.
You put a +1 button, if you want
people to recommend your
site, recommend your content.
And what we're seeing
is really,
exactly what we expect.
When we pick the signals that
we choose to highlight and
feature in Google Search, we
pick them because we think
they matter to people.
And the results we're seeing
are they do matter.
People find those to be more
interesting, more compelling,
more reasons to click
on those results.
Let's go on to another
feature.
So you saw this in the story.
You saw that there was this
capability, where, right in
Seth's experience of using
Google, whether he happened to
be in Maps or he happened to be
in Search or he happened to
be in Gmail, a notification
came in, which took him to
this message I sent.
I had sent a post out
there that said,
Seth, this is for you.
I'd like you to check
this out.
And I did it in a way that was
in context, that was really in
the flow of what Seth is doing,
what we were doing
together, so he had a reason
to engage with it.
So how do you do this?
How do you help users do this?
Short answer is copy and paste
that into your page next.
A slightly longer answer-- and
I'm going to go a tad bit
deeper on this one, because
there's a pattern here, which
is the way that we do all
of the rich, interactive
capabilities that we let you
drop into your website.
And the pattern is, you put in
one line of JavaScript, but
you put it in once.
It's sort of amortized over all
of the different social
capabilities from Google that
you might want to include.
You put in that one line.
And then everything else is
putting in markup on the page,
just like all the other elements
on your page, with
enough information for us,
Google, to know how to render
it and what to do with it.
So in this case, you see, at the
top of this button markup,
that the class is g dash
interactive post.
That tells us that you want us
to render that as a Share
button that lets Seth share a
message with me, let's me
share a message with Seth.
He also told us what
should happen when
someone clicks on it.
So if you go through it, you
can see that the call to
action is View Menu.
We didn't guess that
was a View Menu.
You decided that, in this case,
the action that you
wanted to facilitate
was viewing a menu.
And you also told us
where should it go.
If he clicks, you told us some
other information to display.
You gave us all information
we need to render this.
I should point out that all of
the examples that we're going
through, today, are shown in
the HTML version, the web
version of it.
There are exactly equivalent
capabilities for Android,
using the Android SDK
style, for iOS.
So we didn't want to go into all
of the different syntactic
details, but, conceptually, it's
exactly the same thing.
You tell us the information
that we need to render it.
And then, the benefit, of
course, Interactive Post
button shows up.
User's share, gets those
conversations going, triggers
those 3x interaction rates.
Let's go onto one more way
that we give you, as an
application developer, a way to
get the information, about
how people are using your app,
into Google, in a way that's
useful to users and therefore
useful to you.
Again, you saw this
in the demo.
I searched for Fandango.
And I saw, not only information
about Fandango in
general, I saw information about
how people, people using
Google+ and Fandango,
are using Fandango.
And in this case, I could see,
here's the information about
what's popular with
Google+ users who
are also using Fandango.
You cans see what the movies
are that they have been
watching trailers of, recently,
can see a little
metadata about it.
And I can see a way
to click into it.
So how did this happen?
How is it that Google now
knows enough, about what
people are doing on Fandango,
to be able to make Search
results better?
And what Fandango did, in their
application, is they put
a little bit of code in.
Again, short version
is, they told us.
How did we know?
They told us.
Well, how did they tell us?
They specified the
user action.
We have a predefined vocabulary
of about a dozen
different actions, so far,
that's covered many dozens
worth of partner integrations,
so we're happy with what we're
finding with the initial.
They said, in this case,
it's someone
has discovered something.
What did they discover?
There's the URL to the movie
they've discovered.
And then there's just a call
at the bottom that says, go
ahead and make this API call
to write this activity-- we
call it a moment, internally--
to Google.
And that's it.
One more thing I'll point out,
that came before all this, is
you noticed, when Seth went
through the flow, there was a
permission dialog, where we said
to the user, hey, is it
OK if Fandango, if Open Table
writes information to Google?
The user said, yes.
The user decided who
could see it.
You, as a developer, don't
have to worry about that.
What yo know is that the user
has already said, it's OK for
you to tell Google, here's
what happened.
And then it's between us and
the user to use that
information correctly and wisely
and in a way that's
value, both to the person doing
the activity and to the
other people who might
care about it.
So we just talked about four
different features for getting
information, from your app, from
your site, into Google.
Let's talk about four features
that go the other way and get
information and services, from
Google, to help make your app,
make your site better.
I'm going to start with
the absolute basics.
You can't do anything with the
user if you don't know who the
user is, right?
You can't provide a better
experience without knowing who
you are providing the
experience for.
So you've seen this.
I think you probably couldn't
get off the escalator, you
couldn't use the Google I/O app
without seeing the Sign-In
with Google button.
And you see it's really
easy as a user.
You click the button.
And you're in.
So what did the app developer
need to do?
What did Open Table need
to do to put that
button on their site?
Well, you're going to see, it's
a very familiar pattern.
They still had that one
line of JavaScript.
They still put in one piece
of markup that said,
hey, I want a button.
In this case, the button,
instead of being a g dash
interactive post button, is
a g dash sign-in button.
And again, you provide just
enough information for Google
to do the right thing
with that sign-in.
So what information do
you need to provide?
Well, you need to tell us,
first line there, that's
called scope, is you need to
say, what permissions are you
asking the user for?
You're asking the user to trust
you to access Google.
What trust are you asking for?
Simplest case is you just
say, you want to login.
Great, a lot of good integration
is done that way.
But because it's all one Google
and all one user, you
get to ask for more
capabilities.
So if, for example, you want
to also access your user's
calendars, just add another
scope saying, hey, may I touch
your calendar?
If you want to access their
YouTube channels, maybe help
them subscribe, just add another
scope saying, hey, may
I access YouTube, may I access
your Drive, may I get your
email address?
All of what Google offers is all
available as an option for
you to ask your user, would you
like to let me do this,
because I'm going to give
you better experience.
That's the scope, a few other
pieces of information, what's
the callback flow,
the mechanics of
actually making this work.
But you put that markup on your
page, and we will render
a Sign-In button and
take it from there.
And you'll get called back with
the permission token, the
authorization token that
you need to go ahead
and do deeper things.
So that's the basics.
First step, you have to
let the user sign-in.
The next thing Seth showed you
is, well, after the user
signed in, we kind of magically
said, hey, user you
might want this app.
Did you know, have an app?
Check it out.
It's kind of cool.
And 40% of the users say, yes,
that's very interesting.
Thank you.
Why is that?
It's because it's in context.
It's like I'm offering the user
something that we know is
relevant to them, right now.
And that's why, not surprisingly
in hindsight, a
lot of people are saying
yes to it.
So what extra work did you, as
a developer, have to do to
enable this second screen
in the sign-in flow?
And you're going to have to
look pretty closely to see
what's different, because
not a lot is different.
This is that same g dash
sign-in button.
The one thing that's different
is, at the bottom, we said,
oh, by the way, here's
my Android app.
And then there's some work, in
the console, where you set it
up to say, hey, I have a project
that actually has a
couple of pieces to it.
But once you've set it up, all
you have to do is tell us
about it, and now we know that
it's Open Table, whether it's
opentable.com, Open Table on
Android, it's all the same
application.
So it's a good time for me to
prompt the user to say, let's
install this app.
And that's enough for us to find
in the Play Store and do
all the other pieces of
the plumbing needed.
You add a line, we take
care of the rest.
So this is actually the news
that we announced in the
keynote this morning.
This is the freshest piece of
news that you're going to see
in this talk today.
As you saw, what Seth
demonstrated, there was a
missing piece of UI.
And there's a missing
piece of code here.
So there's no code to support
the no UI that we demoed.
So what is it that we
didn't show you?
Well, what we didn't show you
is, after Seth pulled out his
phone, tapped on Open Table,
he didn't have to login.
He didn't have to
say who he was.
type a password.
He didn't have to do
anything else.
Because why should I he?
He has already signed
into Open Table.
And he's already told
his phone who he is.
That's enough.
So how do you, as a developer,
enable that cross client
single sign-on?
And the answer is that console I
alluded to before, just tell
us, tells us it's
the same app.
So you've told us
your website.
You've told us your app.
You tell us that they're
the same thing.
And we take it from there.
That is it.
We will take care of both the
download option and the
seamless cross platform
sign-in.
Last feature that I'm going to
drill a little bit into is
what you see here.
We're on "Forbes." The user is
browsing the website, reading
an article.
They're done with the article
and up came a teaser to say,
here are some other content, on
"Forbes", that you might be
interested in reading.
They click through.
They saw some content.
I'm going to take a chance
here and go back.
That was fast.
We'll see how far back I go.
Here I am reading it.
I'm watching the-- yeah,
I'm getting the nod.
So here I am on this site.
I'm reading forbes.com
on my mobile
phone, reading an article.
Watch what happens when I'm done
reading the article and
start to scroll back up.
Oh, bottom of the screen,
up opens this
recommendations tab .
I look through.
I find other content that's
interesting to me.
I pick on it.
And now I'm reading more
content on "Forbes."
So this is something
we just announced
and launched on Monday.
This is available
to all of you.
What does it take to
implement this?
We're adding a significant
new capability
to your mobile website.
You've now added a whole, new
user exploration and browsing
capability, built on a lot of
different signals about what
users are reading and what
common content is, relevant to
what other content, what are
other articles written by the
author, using a whole
bunch of things?
How do you put that
onto your site?
The answer is, remember that one
line of JavaScript I keep
referring to?
Just put it on your site.
And there's a console where
you check a box
saying, yes, please.
I want mobile content
recommendations.
And you get them.
And we do the rest.
That same partner dinner, that
Seth was talking about last
night, we were talking to a
couple of developers, who are
kind of jet-lagged, because
they had just
flown in from Turkey.
And before getting on the plane,
in Turkey, for their
flight to Google I/O, so they
could be in the Sandbox here,
they read about our
announcement.
And they said, oh, that
sounds pretty.
So they got off the plane.
And they added mobile content
recommendations to their
website and had it done before
they got to their hotel.
And that was what we were
hoping were the kind of
stories that we would hear.
And Tamindir, in Turkey,
now has mobile content
recommendations.
You have to read Turkish, on
your phone, to be able to
appreciate the quality of
the recommendations.
But that's how mobile content
recommendations work.
So you just saw a medium
deep dive.
I'm going to let Seth put a
little bit of context around
all of this.
SETH STERNBERG: So as you guys
can see, at the beginning, we
said that the Google+ Platform
was really about connecting a
user's Google experience with
your applications and letting
the user take the best of what
they're finding, inside your
applications, inside
your websites, and
bringing it back to Google.
And now I think you can see some
of the features that are
really making this happen.
So if we know, for example,
that a user is connecting,
with your application, on your
website, guardian.co.uk, and
we know that they have an
Android device, we can say to
that user, hey, do you
want the Android app?
Because the user is probably
really interested in your
Android app, because they're
choosing to connect with you.
Or giving users, in your
application, an incredibly
rich way for them to share what
they're doing, right now
inside their application, and
asking their friends, at
Google, across all Google
properties, to join you.
If the friend's at Search, if
they're in Maps, no matter
where they are, YouTube, they
will see that notification and
click on it and see what their
friend wants them to do inside
your property.
So it's a seamless experience
for users.
And it's a seamless experience
for developers to make this
all a reality.
And if you think about what
we're really trying to do, for
all of you, the developers,
other than, hopefully, to
create something that's
really, really easy to
integrate and create a great
user experience, it's really
gets down to some of the core
business metrics that you guys
care about.
Every one of these features
is designed, in one way or
another, to either bring you
more users, help your content
get discovered across all Google
properties, in Maps, in
Search, on people's Android
phones, in Google+ stream, no
matter where people are in
Google, help them find more of
your content.
And then what Google does best
is send people traffic that's
relevant and engaged.
When someone clicks on that View
Menu button or Watch a
Video button or a read an
article or comment, they are
going to your mobile app or
they are going to your
website, because they have
something that they
specifically want to do.
They're very, very likely to
engage, because their friend
asked them to take a very
specific action.
So a bunch of these features are
designed to bring you more
traffic from Google.
Another core goal is to drive
you more engagement inside
your mobile apps or inside
your websites.
We got asked, frequently, when
we launched-- on just Monday,
so just two days ago--
the mobile content
recommendations that you saw
from "Forbes."
And we got asked, why
did you launch it on
the mobile web first?
And the answer is, we talked
to a lot of publishers.
And we're finding out from them
the dynamics of their
businesses.
And they told us, hey, our
number one problem for users
on mobile web is that
they bounce.
There's no engagement.
They come in from the Google+
stream or a Twitter stream or
a Facebook stream.
They read one article for like
15 seconds, and they leave.
And I never had a chance
to keep that
user inside my property.
We knew mobile web was the
problem, because user's who
already had the Android app or
an iOS app, they stay longer.
So we chose to solve the problem
for mobile web first,
where the developers and
publishers were having the
biggest pain point.
So features designed to drive
more engagement, more page
views, more time inside
your site.
Or the seamless, single sign-on
that was announced at
I/O this morning, if you are
able to have a user connect
once, on you're desktop website
or on your mobile app,
because it works both ways.
It goes from desktop web to
mobile, and it goes from
mobile back to desktop web.
The user connects once, and you
now know who that user is
across your entire service.
This is not about a user
connecting with you on mobile
and then, separately, you on
desktop, but rather it is you
forming a relationship with your
user and your service, no
matter what device they're on.
And you can now give them
a completely relevant
experience, which, hopefully,
enables you to drive more
engagement with that user, no
matter the property, and also
monetize better.
Because you now know what a user
is more interested in,
your own statistics.
You know what a user is doing
across your different
properties, so more page use.
And then, finally, more
seamless, right?
We were trying to create
a completely integrated
experience, for a user,
across mobile and
web, mobile and desktop.
To users, they don't really
think, oh, I'm looking at CNN
on my Android.
And then I'm looking
at CNN on my iPad.
And then, oh, it's
CNN on desktop.
They just use CNN.
They just use Fancy
or Beautylish.
so to them, it's about
a relationship with
you and your service.
And we're trying to enable
all of you to create that
completely seamless experience
for the users.
So we've been doing a lot.
David's engineering team,
my product team have
been very, very busy.
A bunch of you are in
the audience, so
thank you very much.
We launched Google+ Sign-In
two months ago,
at the end of February.
And if you look at the pace with
which we've issuing new
product updates and bringing new
capabilities to market, by
early April, Gigya and Janrain
made Google+ Sign-In
available, to thousands and
thousands of developers, to
integrate very simply with
their platforms.
And then we took the app
activities, that you're able
to write us, when a user
connects with Google, inside
your app, and began making
available in Search, first in
movies and in music, with
people like Fandango and
Slacker and Shazam.
And of course, more vertical
is to come.
But get that social activity
into Search so we can provide
users a much more relevant,
engaging experience in Search
and drive you more engaged
users back to your
applications.
And then we did the content
recommendations, just a few
days ago, driving more
traffic, driving more
engagement inside your mobile
websites, letting users
discover content they simply
would not have discovered.
Developers, publishers were
losing traffic in mobile web,
because users didn't
have a good way to
find interesting content.
And so now we've created a way
for those users to find
something that's truly
interesting, truly special
based on what the article is
about, that they're reading,
or what their friends
have liked
inside that given property.
And then, just today, seamless
authentication, user connects
on a mobile app, and when they
load your service on a web
browser, they are
just connected.
And trust me, there
will be much more
to come very quickly.
We are going to stay very busy
to keep driving this
connection between Google and
the rest of the internet and,
hopefully, bring a lot of value
to both users and you,
the developers.
So we're here at Google I/O.
This is an overhead shot of
the Google+ Sandbox
that's out there.
I very much invite you guys to
go see all the different
publishers and all the different
developers, that
have come to Google I/O, with
really stellar Google+
integrations.
So there are over 50 developers,
outside, who had
various forms of interesting
integrations with Google+
Sign-In, with content
recommendations, with
over-the-air installs,
interactive posts.
Lots of different stuff is on
display there, which could,
hopefully, give you
some ideas.
I think it's about 20
developers, every day, that
are going to cycle through,
through day one, day
two, and day three.
So you'll have lots
to look at.
If you come back tomorrow,
there'll be a new set of folks
to get inspiration from.
I'd really invite you
to go take a look.
A couple that I just thought
were pretty cool.
So Air New Zealand is here.
And they have this, of course,
Google+ Sign-In integrated.
And when you sign-in,
they've done
something a little special.
It's send me your wish, which
we thought was just cute.
So you see your friends,
right?
And you can send a wish
to your friends.
And when you do that, you just
go ahead, select a friend,
type in a wish, it gets sent
to Air New Zealand.
And then, of course, you can
let people know about it.
DAVID GLAZER: Seth,
you left off the
most important feature.
You can also choose the fairy's
wardrobe from her closet.
SETH STERNBERG: Really?
That's good to know.
I did not know that one.
Or another one that we thought
was really neat, "Glamour." so
David pointed out that
you can get any
Google permission here.
So it happened really fast.
But you can see that now I've
signed in to "Glamour," using
Google+ Sign-In, I'm actually,
already, subscribed to the
YouTube channel.
Because one of the capabilities
that YouTube has
is to subscribe to their
channels through an API.
And that's one of many APIs
that you could ask for.
Like David said, you could
have asked for access to
someone's calendar, to put
events on their calendar, or
asked for access
to their Drive.
So this is a really great
example of someone going
beyond just the straight social
functionality and
saying, hey, when someone
connects with us, since we
have an active YouTube channel,
we'd like to have
them subscribe to our YouTube
channel, too.
And we thought that
was pretty neat.
So we've got a lot of sessions,
that are going to be
happening over the next couple
of days, that are about the
Google+ Platform.
So this is day one.
I encourage you guys
to take a look.
It's in the I/O application as
well, where you can scan
through, or on
developers.google.com/IO.
So these are the day
one activities.
And then there's a bunch of
activities on day two as well,
all about how to really take
advantage of these features
that, hopefully, should be
there to both create an
awesome user experience inside
your properties and drive you
more unique users, more traffic,
more engagement, more
page views, and create a
seamless experience between
mobile and web.
So with that, I think we have
a few minutes left.
And we'd love to take any
questions that you folks might
have from the audience.
DAVID GLAZER: There are a
couple of microphones.
Please use them, because this
is also being live streamed.
There's also, for people who
are watching at some of the
remote events, there's a link
that, I'm told, you can see
Nexus stream, where can submit
questions online.
And I've got that open if anyone
finds that channel and
wants to use it.
SETH STERNBERG: So go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Tantek Celik from Mozilla.
As part of the Google+ Platform,
do you guys have any
plans to support any of the
social web standards, such as
PubSubHubbub, co-developed by
various Google folks, both for
subscribing to Google+ feeds
in realtime and being on
Google+ and being able to
subscribe to feeds, across the
web, in realtime?
DAVID GLAZER: We have
no immediate plans.
We've obviously looked very
closely at those standards.
We have people who helped
build those standards.
You've been part of the
community that's helped define
some of those standards.
What we've looked at, with a lot
of aspects of Google+, is
really not just, on auto-pilot,
following the
model that made sense before and
looking at each aspect of
sharing, each aspect of
relationships and saying,
which ones do we know we want to
replicate, which ones do we
know we want to do something
new and different on--
I'll get concrete in a second--
and which ones do we
not know yet, so we're
going to go slow?
So, for example, on the basic
relationship model, we knew
that we wanted to not follow
the standard model and
introduced the concept
of circles.
And we think that that has led
to a whole richer set of
engagement opportunities in the
product and therefore it
ripples into how the
platform works.
Around the stream itself, we
have been watching how the
conversational environment
evolves inside Google+.
And we really like the kinds
of conversations that are
fostered in there.
And we are leery that, if we too
easily allow people to do
what could be perceived as
junk mail entering the
conversation or perceived as
fragmenting the conversation,
it would hurt the nature
of and the quality of.
So that's why we've been going
very slowly around anything
that provides that kind of
stream access in either
direction that you're
talking about.
There are some basic
things out there.
I'm sure you know about them.
We have a lot of partners who
are using those basic things.
There's a car out there, where
you can watch your Google+
posts in the Mercedes.
I think they're on
the third floor.
They've put something
together.
But nothing to say about the
specific standards that you
asked about.
SETH STERNBERG: How about
the person in the back.
AUDIENCE: Sure, I love the
automated app install on my
Android phone.
Is there anything you
can do to make it
automated on an iPad?
Or is that Apple's decision?
And then the unrelated follow-up
is, my main problem
with sharing things on Google+
is none of my friends know to
click that red box in the upper
right-hand corner of
their toolbar.
Is there any kind of more
obvious way you could make
that, if you just sent this
right into their email?
SETH STERNBERG: So to your
second question, the
notifications that
go into Google.
So a point I made is, the
Google+ Platform is very much
about connecting a user with
their entire Google
experience, across all the
properties, with your
applications.
And you've seen lots of features
from Android, to
Search, to Maps.
Those notifications are one of
the things that we actually
find users click on quite
a fair amount.
Now one thing to note, as a
developer, is we're very
careful with the
notifications.
We've heard from users, when we
were creating the sharing
features with the Google+
Platform, that users did not--
they were almost scared--
of spamming friends.
They really don't want
to spam friends.
But when they do want to share
to friends, they want to make
absolutely certain that
their friends are
going to see something.
And so the way we've designed
the notifications is that, if
someone's specific name
is called out in
that sharing box--
which actually, as a developer,
if you've pulled
down the user's friends list,
you now have my list of people
in my circles, you can, even in
your own UI, let me select
friends, and then choose
to prepopulate--
I think it's up to 10 names--
inside that box, individually.
And then those notifications
will trigger.
Just on the basis of a circle,
the notifications won't
trigger, because we think
that that is too loud.
If I shared something with a
circle of 100 people, not all
100 people, probably, should
get that notification.
But if I actually chose to call
someone specifically out,
that person should get
the notification.
And not only will they get that
notification across every
Google property, they'll also
get an email, as long as they
haven't changed their
default settings.
So it's as close as we could
get to guaranteed delivery.
DAVID GLAZER: It might be
they're just ignoring you.
I did a test, with my family, a
little while ago, where I'd
been posting a fair number of
things and hearing a little
bit but some crickets back.
So I did a sort of loud, caps
post saying, hey, could you
just let me know if
you get this?
And they all said, oh
yeah, we get it.
We just didn't have anything
to say to you before.
So I was like, OK.
SETH STERNBERG: To your second
question about iOS, so, as you
probably noticed, in the
story, throughout the
presentation, every feature that
we are launching Google+
Platform is cross platform,
for Android, iOS, and web,
with the exception of the
really, super seamless
one-click install from
web to mobile.
The only reason is because
we cannot do that on iOS.
We don't have quite the level
of access, in iOS, that we
would need to make that as
seamless as possible for
users, to create a good
user experience.
If we could do it, we would.
But right now, we just can't.
So it's the one feature that,
unfortunately, we can't make
cross platform.
Fire away.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is Chris from Austria.
You mentioned a possibility to
connect the Android app with
the Google+ Sign-In button
on the website.
Is there any mechanism
or possibility
to specify two apps?
So I'm thinking multiple app
developers have a free version
and a paid version or even
multiple apps, so is there any
mechanism for this?
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
So we've looked at that.
We want to do that.
We want to do it once we're sure
that we have shut off the
abuse potential of an
ill-intentioned developer
using that in a bad way.
And we think we know how to do
that, but until we're positive
that we can get that right and
handle all of that, we're
going to go slowly there.
So yeah, the use case you
described is a great use case.
There's another use case, where
some developers have a
family of apps, where they've
chosen to provide three kinds
of functionality as separate,
top-level apps.
It's a fine pattern.
But we wanted to start, with the
one-to-one, which is what
you saw, which covers
the majority.
SETH STERNBERG: How about
the person behind you?
I think he's been
waiting longer.
Yeah, on the front.
Yeah, mic.
AUDIENCE: John Blossom, Shore
Communications and Content Nation.
I enjoy using the service.
One thing that you just did,
you activated comments in
Blogger, which is has been one
that's actually made me want
to blog for the first
time in a long time.
Because I know that my community
will come with me
and stay engaged
in the content.
What's the roadmap for exposing
that to mainstream
publishers, who may be
interested in that sort of
engagement?
Are you getting feedback that
they are, in fact, interested
in it, on services such
as Huff Post?
Question two, as long as I
waited, it's a pain in the
butt, if you want to expose your
content to the public,
and you have specific circles
you don't want to receive it.
Like my dad really doesn't want
to hear about everything
that I do in my professional
life.
Public goes to him anyway,
regardless.
Is that ever going to change?
So two things, thank you.
SETH STERNBERG: Great
question.
In terms of the second
question,
it's not on the roadmap.
So, right now, if you
do choose public,
that does go to everybody.
Obviously, circles were designed
to let you decide
what to share with very
specific people.
I've actually not heard that
request before but duly noted.
For the second, so like you
said, we just put out comments
in Blogger.
It was our first shot at making
comments really great
and crossing them between the
conversation that's happening
on Google+, on a given topic,
and putting that into Blogger
and making it available there.
We've seen interesting demand
and even a few hacks out in
market, trying to take those
comments, that commenting
system, from Blogger, and bring
it into other sites.
But we don't have anything that
we could announce on that
at present.
DAVID GLAZER: Is it something
that you'd be interested in
using on sites you manage
or sites you visit?
AUDIENCE: I think that
a lot of folks would.
I'm using it on my sites now,
because I'm using a blogging
mechanism within our site.
Just look at what happened, say,
on the "Huffington Post".
People have options there.
They can Facebook.
They can Twitter.
At minimum, there should
be an x to be able to
say that it's Google+.
But it seems like what you're
saying is, you're creating the
ability for them to create
engagement much more
efficiently, with all these
other things surrounding the
commenting mechanism.
So this could be icing on
the cake, it seems.
DAVID GLAZER: Thank you.
SETH STERNBERG: Thanks.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You talked earlier
about plus naming for
notifications.
I'm wondering what's
the upper limit?
SETH STERNBERG: Sorry.
Could you start again?
I couldn't hear you at first.
AUDIENCE: You talked earlier
about plus naming for
notifications.
I'm wondering, what's the upper
limit for the number of
people you can plus name
in a post, to get those
notifications, that prevents my
users from getting 10,000
emails with 10,000 other
people's names in them?
SETH STERNBERG: Right now,
I believe it's set at 10.
So you can do up to 10 names,
specifically called out inside
a share box, which you
can pass into it.
So if you built your own UI to
let a user select names, you
can pass that in.
The user will then see
the share box.
And they'll see those
names listed out.
So we made sure that users
would know exactly what's
happening at each step.
But right now it's 10.
DAVID GLAZER: And the intent
behind that is we're trying
to, again, match real world
conversations, where there is
a mode of, I want to talk, very
directly, to three or
four people.
And it's probably very
important to me
that they hear it.
And they probably
want to hear it.
It's unlikely I want to start an
intimate conversation with
97 people at once.
It's possible, but that's not
the case we optimized for.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Jonathan Frankel,
School of Rock.
This might be a little bit
outside of the scope of what
you're talking about.
But we're really interested in,
if you have any plans, and
if you do have any plans are you
willing to share plans, to
allow for some enterprise
control of Google+ accounts?
SETH STERNBERG: Sorry,
enterprise control?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So right now, we can
provision accounts.
In the cPanel obviously,
we can enable
Google+ for the accounts.
But we don't have any
direct control
over the Google+ accounts.
They're kind of connected to
but, I guess, separate from
the Google account
that we control.
And I think it would be
really useful for us.
It seems like we could create
a community, which would be
very useful for us, if we
just had a little bit
more top-down control.
DAVID GLAZER: There's work
happening there.
I don't know their
exact roadmap.
But if you come find me
afterwards, I can get your
contact info and put you in
touch with the product
manager, who's working
to do that.
What we find is that, if we look
at the world of all the
people using Google apps, in
their domain, there's a set of
requirements that we have
done that satisfy a
chunk of the pie.
And then there's a richer set of
requirements, before we can
get at the next set, to
say, yes, this works
for me and so on.
And we're just working our
way through that list.
I don't know where your
requirements would fit.
But I can connect you.
SETH STERNBERG: I guess we'll
take the last question.
AUDIENCE: Allen Firstenberg.
Can you elaborate a little bit
on, if and how, the Google+
Moments are going to be
integrating, in any way, with
the Game Center?
SETH STERNBERG: So when we
first announced Google+
Sign-In, we talked about app
activities, or you're
referring to them as Moments.
So just to make sure that
everybody is on the same page,
that's how you, as a developer
or publisher, can let us know
what users are doing
inside your apps.
Now we want to take that data
and put it in the most
interesting, most contextually
relevant place for our users.
What we're not particularly
interested in is only throwing
them at people on that kind
of timeline basis.
Because if you read an article
about Costa Rica, right now, I
don't really care.
But if I start doing a search
for Costa Rica, what my friend
has written on, on Costa Rica,
commented on, on Costa Rica,
read about Costa Rica,
I probably care.
Or if I'm doing a Map search
for Costa Rica or San Jose,
Costa Rica, I probably
care then.
So we want to take this
information and use it in
context, which should be a
better user experience and
send you all, as developers and
publishers, more qualified
traffic back.
The first place we launched it
was on people's profiles.
So if I went specifically to
your profile and you said,
yes, I get access to that,
because I'm in a circle that
you've named, then
I can see it.
And we're not spamming
it at people.
But if I'm interested in what
you're doing, I can go see
what you've done
in a given app.
The second place that
we publicly talked
about was in Search.
And you saw us launch movies
and music verticals, into
Search, using that same data.
What I can certainly promise you
is that you will continue
to see the same kind of data
roll throughout other Google
properties, where
it makes sense.
The way we think about it is
that users have very specific
intents as they use Maps versus
Search versus Play, as
you mentioned, versus
the Google+ stream.
And we want to make sure that
we're doing a great job giving
the users exactly what they
would want, based on the
reason they're using a given
product, as we think about
rolling that data
across Google.
So thank you all very much.
I really appreciate it.
Please do stop by all the
developers booths outside in
the Sandbox.
DAVID GLAZER: Try out the
new feedback mechanism.
Love to hear what you think,
so we can tune
this up for next time.
And check the Sandbox, check the
other talks if you want to
go deeper on any of the things
we talked about.
That's where you'll find
the deep dives.
Thank you.
SETH STERNBERG: Thank you all